you always have a great sense of humor
even with this new TV show that you're
putting together with Kevin Hart you
play pranks on celebrities and you
played pranks on each other his prank
was fantastic the fake TV show it was
called having my baby with Nick Cannon
the brilliant thing was when it's time
to market the show we pranked the world
and put it out there on E like that was
a real show you guys that was like the
world this was so great there was a fake
TV show be the next one to have Nick
Cannon's baby oh I pissed so many people
off NBC The Today Show even did a news
report about sort of outrage that Nick
Cannon now is putting himself on human
life is not a game show I who said that
that was like CNN or something like that
Kevin Hart didn't he buy you a condom
machine like an actual kind yes
vending machine and filled it with
Magnum condoms
[Music]
that's the great I don't even know where
I'm gonna put this thing it's just
sitting in my garage right now that is
fantastic